les animaux qu'on se met à réfléchir on
arrive à la conclusion qu'il faut
libérer les animaux je pense que je suis
vous franchirez vegan c'est comme ça
maintenant il y en a partout
[Musique]
mon vin est-il vegan demande la saq
j'étale un burger sans viande en rupture
de stock
il y a quelque chose dans l'air du temps
végétarien végétalien et le mode de vie
multeam le véganisme déjà maintenant
j'en faisais presque parfait pour noël
et bien je reçois taux de ma
belle-famille carnivores et je leur sers
un repas sain porcin vegan à des
messieurs
lui c'est le chef jean-philippe un des
visages du mouvement vegan mais d'abord
qu'est ce que c'est vegan ça veut dire
ne rien manger qui proviennent des
animaux pas de viande pas de l'est pas
d'oeuf mais pas de miel non plus ça
c'est pour le côté régime alimentaire et
il ya aussi un côté éthique
aucun produit animal ça veut aussi dire
pas de cuir pas de laine ou de plumes
pas de visite aussi être non plus
[Musique]
marie giroux et coauteur dans que sèche
sur la question c'est vraiment plus
qu'un régime alimentaire en effet c'est
vraiment une position et postures
politiques
on veut faire changer des choses pour
libérer projet selon une enquête récente
de l'université de dalhousie
près d'un canadien sur dix ne mange plus
de viande et ils sont plus nombreux
encore à décider d'en manger moins on
les appelle les flexitariens l'adieu à
la vie de carnivores petit à petit tu es
déjà qu'ils vont l'incorporer donc une
journée par semaine deux journées par
semaine
enfin certains points ah ça fait
quelques monde j'ai pas mangé de viande
n'est plus de besoin les raisons sont
multiples mais l'environnement est l'un
des arguments qui revient souvent
l'élevage principalement industrielle
c'est 14% des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre autant que tous les transports
sûrs
nous ce qu'on dit c'est qu'il faut
réduire essentiellement au niveau global
de 50 % la consommation de viande d'ici
2050 ce qui inclut que ceux qui en
consomment davantage comme les nord
américains réduisent davantage leur
consommation de viande et c'est
exactement ce à quoi s'emploie le chef
jean philippe
si les gens réduisent leur consommation
de viande ne serait ce qu'une fois par
semaine ou un repas par semaine pour
commencer
s'il le faut c'est déjà un pas dans la
bonne direction on n'est pas obligé
d'aller vivre dans une commune puisse
porter des sandales pour être vega n'en
payant vivement donc parfaitement normal
mal et comme il pense que les débats
d'idées des vegan peuvent être un peu
aride il utilise l'humour
savez vous qu'il y avait des rumeurs que
jésus aurait peut-être être élégant mais
après vérification il ré jamais été
capable de réunir jauge le retour d'un
repos rien c'est impossible
mais tout n'est pas que dérision au pays
des vegan surtout en france
[Applaudissements]
les activistes sont des membres de
l'association 269 l'ice libération
animale
des vegan venus passer un message aux
majeurs de viande
des coups médiatiques dans la rue devant
les bouchons d'accord
à bord et vous de voir son avenir
l'abruti adv egan de mer point de
confrontation mais des dégradations au
québec ici en novembre des boucheries de
drummondville vandalisé une autre dans
le mile end l'année dernière ou encore
dans glee fenton je sais pas des effets
contre-productifs certaine violence
valérie giroux a une approche plus
philosophique mais elle tient à ce que
le véganisme soit un mouvement social
qui dérange
je peux comprendre quand même que
certains certains animalistes français
notamment ceux des annonces à doite on
doit y aller par la voix plus plus
politique plus confrontation elle que
les airs mais tant qu'ils sont vraiment
les récents problèmes la racine du
problème qui serait donc d'élever des
animaux pour les tuer même si certains
mettent tous leurs efforts pour soutenir
les petits producteurs respectueux et
malaga c'est vraiment de manger moins de
viande mais de la choisir mieux
pascal leboucher serait-il lui aussi
flexitariens on peut jouer que ces
termes ne pas mal moi je suis un
omnivore sélectif
oui je mange de la viande mais pour un
boucher ce qu'il a à coeur c'est la
qualité de vie des animaux pour qu'ils
deviennent de vrais ambassadeurs de leur
terroir
on veut que les animaux respecte leur
comportement naturel un cochon c'est se
poser fouine est un poulet se pose et
qui causé donc on veut que les animaux
aient accès à l'extérieur les ruminants
au pâturage et une alimentation en
fonction de la réel besoin génétique et
il est possible qu'après avoir désosser
un boeuf du museau à la queue il se
retrouve lui aussi à manger des
boulettes vegan
et légumes des champignons et du boeuf
haché lagré dian secret